I'm going to be talking about a topic
that is very familiar to many of you but
I'll be talking about it in a slightly
different way this topics on creating
digital content sharing it online and
participating in basically any sort of
online social computing space this is
how we connect with other people how we
express ourselves show humor show
attachment to other people and maintain
relationships and today we're going to
talk about this all through the lens of
aging what it means to be an older adult
and participate in these sorts of spaces
so to help you understand why this
problem space is important and
interesting I'll start with a quick
story so this is Ethel Ethel is 105
years old so at 105 you would imagine
she has sort of normal age-related
memory loss so she forgets people's
names or her relationships to them and
she's becoming somewhat socially
withdrawn so her daughter Alice is often
looking for opportunities to engage her
mother in social interaction her
daughter Alice knows how important it is
to keep her mother engaged and
stimulated but her mother won't touch an
iPad or anything else that looks like
technology so now consider John over
here John has the early stages of
dementia John at one time though however
he's a he's an active computer user one
time he ordered order after order of the
same exact item and these boxes kept
arriving at the house John was also on
Facebook and John's posting things like
I'm headed out of town for two weeks I'm
headed off to the bank as well right so
things that shouldn't really be posted
online now John and Alice are married so
Alice sees what's happening with her
husband and also the situation with her
mother Alice is pretty tech savvy as an
older adult she has over a dozen online
accounts for her banking information
health social connections so at this
point in time you know she doesn't want
to hand over power of attorney like her
husband has had to do to her so she asks
her children who are also in their 60s
in older adults to just check on her
from time to time the best we can do
right now is she says here are my login
credentials for my bank account just
kind of peek at my files and make sure
everything looks squared away
go time to
I'm look at my facebook feed and my
Facebook profile make sure I'm not
connecting with any sort of unsavory
folks um so this is really complex right
and then Alice's children also have
their own desires they want to connect
with their grandmother and their father
but their grandmother doesn't use the
same sorts of platforms that they use
and their grant and their father often
doesn't remember them or his
relationship to them so in today's talk
I'm going to introduce several systems
that help us think about what it means
to design for staying active and engaged
online throughout the lifespan so as I
started allude to it this is a really
important topic for many reasons one is
that as we get older our social networks
tend to shrink but there's also this
very clearly established relationship
between having late-life social support
and having positive physical and mental
health outcomes then the flip side of
that is that social isolation can be
associated with higher rates of
disability slower recovery from illness
and even early death so it's really
important that we think about ways of
helping people maintain their active
social lives throughout the lifespan now
the good news is that recent analyses
show that if you're active online as an
older adult you're less likely to feel
depressed social Eisley socially
isolated or lonely again some bad news
back in 2014
still 41% of older adults this is people
in the u.s. 65 and older based on the
Pew Research data we're still offline
now this gap is closing some but there
are a significant portion of older
adults in the US who are still offline
one of the contributing factors to being
offline is disability and so as we know
as we age it becomes a very complex
experience with changing values changing
experiences and needs but also changing
abilities so if you think of even the
youngest cohort of older adults and this
is US census data even people 65 to 69
one in four has a severe communicative
cognitive or physical disability couple
that with the striking report from the
Alzheimer's Association one in three
people is expected to
least of older individuals passing away
with dementia or Alzheimer's disease
this is very pervasive when we think
about age-related disability so this is
the topic for our conversation today now
in HCI though we tend to start you know
we think about this as a way of solving
problems of Aging so we think about
technology as helping people remember
medications or preventing wandering
behavior now these are important issues
but they're only one aspect of the
experience of what it means to get older
what about creativity what about social
longing forming new relationships new
partnerships these aspects really aren't
often examined within the literature
it's much more as computer scientists
we're often comfortable with identifying
a problem and then knowing when we've
arrived at a very clear solution to some
sort of aging related problem so this is
part of my theoretical framing and it
draws from the field of critical
gerontology that sort of destabilizes
these narratives around what it means to
be an older person a couple of that with
my view of cognition so typically we
approach cognition from an information
processing theoretical
within an individual's head and instead
when we're dealing with individuals with
cognitive impairment that puts the
burden on that individual as lacking as
having a deficit but instead if we start
to view cognition as distributed across
people time space and even our cultural
practices that changes fundamentally how
we approach system design and how we
study our technologies in the field so
instead of studying the individual and
perhaps a cognitive impairment located
within that person we can study an
intelligent system of activity a
caregiver working alongside an
individual with a cognitive impairment
we can study the system of activity that
includes technology we can start looking
at cognition as an emergent property of
interaction so cognition is happening
it's there it's there for us to study
it's not what's missing within an
individual and we can also start
thinking about the role that technology
can play in this process of meaning
making so again I'll be talking a lot
about this and
system of dyads working in co-located
spaces and health technology can fit
into that have we seen anyone study how
much someone tends to start distributing
their their cognition as they start to
age so you know things that I used to
try to keep in my own head all the time
I still do we is there some curve where
we see like people start to you know
post-it notes on places but for minor
things in the environment or ask others
to help with them and do we know like
what that actually looks like absolutely
there's a whole line of work that's
starting to think about that using
distributed cognition as one theoretical
lens we could talk about it later if you
want during the discussion but
absolutely I think that's an important
part of us understanding what it means
to live with a cognitive impairment and
my my view of a cognitive impairment is
that we all have them at various times
in our life right it could be medication
induced it could be stress I've had
three kids after I have a baby I
definitely have a different level of
cognitive functioning than I do at other
times and so we think about cognitive
impairment as working throughout all of
our lives not just as a particular
condition that an older person might
have um okay so just to tell you a
little bit about Who I am and what I do
so I'm primarily a qualitative
researcher I start out by going to the
field I work in therapy clinics
retirement communities schools nursing
homes and I start by doing in-depth
observations and interviews with a
variety of stakeholders from there we
start to design new sorts of prototypes
that help us understand things so these
prototypes generally will we'll think
about testing them for initial
accessibility and appeal but then we put
them back out into the field with our
field partners for weeks months and even
years at a time and here we're really
looking for things like changing
communication practices as someone now
adopted this technology over time in a
way that previously they hadn't are
people more motivated to interact and to
communicate socially are people
communicating or interacting in a way
that's now more independent than they
previously did and then with that with
these long term understandings of these
systems in the field we can start to
contribute back to our fundamental
theories of human social behavior and
our practices with technology so to say
it very simply
I'm an ethnographer qualitative
researcher who builds systems as a way
of understanding phenomena in the world
so today I'll show you or I'll share
with you just a couple of these
different systems and these different
contexts of study the first one involves
the woman you met in the introduction
this is Ethel and this study is about
audio enhanced paper photos this work
was done a couple years ago but I still
think it's relevant to our discussion
today this is a case study that focuses
on Ethel's last year of life so we
started out by doing observations and
interviews with Ethel's family now this
is the wall in her room okay this is
pretty characteristic of a lot of the
older individuals that we work with
having lots of printed family photos
displayed around to share with other
people we found out that these are
particularly important as a way for
Alice Ethel's daughter to engage her in
conversation so Alice says I come into
Ethel's room say a few things and she
doesn't really interact in the
conversation but if you start talking
about who someone is in a foot in a
picture and do you remember that person
it gives a focal point for communicating
so we're thinking about in the early
stages of this project building on this
practice of sharing paper photos and so
within the field of HCI there's a long
history of enhancing physical objects
and printed materials with audio or
sounds at the moment and so the work
today will build on this long history
but at the time of this study there
really wasn't anything available for an
end user a non-technical end-user
to create their own interactive paper
documents on the fly and so we created
the tap and play system to address this
and this system allows the user with
this is a commercial Livescribe pen with
dot pattern paper to sketch out an
interface and program it and say when
someone taps on this region I want it to
play this particular message or I want
it to recognize handwriting so the
system works like this so it recognizes
any sort of user-defined polygon on
interactive dot patterned paper then
using this custom control panel so this
is the authoring interface is the pen
paper and this custom control panel over
there you can decide whether the region
plays audio
or recognizing handwriting you can
decide what sort of interaction should
make this execute so this is important
these look very basic it can recognize
more complex gestures but the difference
between a pen down and a single tap
gesture is huge for this population we
found time and time again for a lot of
the older adults we're working with when
they touch the pen to the paper they
expected the magic to happen right and
so being able to author at that level
was pretty important but then you can
also do other things with these regions
so you can associate this with a word in
a lexicon to say Reckitt when when
someone writes something in here
recognize these particular key words or
do whatever was saved over in this so it
concert' in this region it can save as a
pointer to another region so all this is
encapsulated in the idea of a region
stored on the pin and then written out
in XML so you can exchange these
customized activities between pens so
this happened place system we developed
over a two-year time period it began
with an early ethnographic study of
speech language therapists using printed
materials as part of rehabilitation for
adults who'd had a stroke and needed to
relearn to speak and regain language and
what we saw here was that they had many
ideas for for enhancing these paper
documents but weren't able to do this on
their own and so we created a first
version of this system deployed it in
the field some things needed to be
improved so we continued to iterate and
finally the tap and play system that I
shared with you we deployed with over
100 people in four different contexts
and today the study with Ethel's family
is just one of those so when we gave
them these materials they created an
interactive audio enhanced photo album
for Ethel so here you can see
interaction across five generations of
her family so children were able to
easily walk up and add songs or their
own stories to Ethel's book this photo
album became this evolving family
artifact so this is one of Ethel
daughters and she is recording a message
here which I'll play is if we set up the
audio correctly hopefully it will work
this is a photograph from the 1940s
it has Ethel and her husband and her
four children in here posing and
this is what her daughter says is her
memory pinecones so you can see it was
very evocative for her as the daughter
who's going back and revisiting these
photos so what's nice about this is here
we're actually studying a group of older
adults so Ethel is 105 and all her
children are in their 80s late 70s and
80s so this is a group of older adults
who are designing content for the
purpose of engaging the family matriarch
and so we started to see a few design
conventions emerge people in this family
called this talking photos so they would
tend to circle a person's face and have
that message attached right to her face
this seemed to work pretty well for
Ethel so they would speak out loud the
family also arranged the photo book in
an interesting way and it's all about
Ethel's experience we thought
chronologically might be important for
this person living going back through
her life but instead it was about family
relationship and the properties of the
paper photos allowed them to layer upon
layer photographs of children as they
age and so Ethel could go back and
listen to the audio messages coupled
with that over time but to me the most
striking thing is how they used these
group photos so we think about a comment
thread on a Facebook photo maybe there's
some teasing and some jokes going on
here is an example of that that played
out in audio enhanced photos so this is
a picture of Ethel and her four children
and her youngest daughter said hello my
name is Mary Ethel is my mother I'm her
youngest and most beautiful child by far
probably the best one of the bunch and
each of these each of her children added
their own message and they're teasing
back and forth and so this is the kind
of experience that Ethel was able to go
back and revisit in her photo album
[Music]
does this kind of work in the past like
the read where an edit where becomes
really awkward here is the more you use
the interface the more it gets sort of
obscured by dots from the pen as people
are pushing on it was this like not
heavily used enough for that to be an
issue I just hate to see the photo end
up getting like yeah totally obscured by
dots very very minor question glad you
brought it up so there's a non-marking
pen tip you can use with the pen so you
can use it basically just as a stylus to
touch instead of making marks on the
paper so they would strategically do
that right there but it's actually you
think about this bug being a feature
when you're going back to look at the
use of the album and you see these
heavily you know these traces of use
that actually can be a nice thing in
addition to the system logs of course
okay so one other thing we can do with
this data now that this family has
generated all of this data for us we can
start to understand the sorts of
messages that they are crafting for
Ethel right so this family and
especially you think about Alice who's
the main message author
this is Ethel's family tree broken down
by Generation and what you see here is
the size of the circle represents how
many messages each person in the family
tree created the the color represents
how many features we coded in that
message so an example of a feature is a
marker of time or a relationship and
over and over again we saw Alice you
would think she's the person who knows
her mother the best interacts with her
daily used this photo album with her
daily recorded messages like this this
is Alice your daughter at the beach
right so she always identified herself
and her relationship whereas a lot of
the other authors and the family members
didn't think to do this so even this
level of authoring gives us some insight
into the types of support that someone
would late life memory loss might need
so now we want to say okay what happened
so we gave this to the family what are
the outcomes everyone wants to know that
so after five weeks we did see some
improvements this is based on survey
data from her Ethel's family members and
nursing staff so people started to note
improved quality of conversations they
had with Ethel that that she had more a
greater interest in
socializing with other people in her
community and that they were even
noticing an improvement in the range of
motion of her right arm so think it 105
the last year if your life any
improvement is a good thing but then
after five months of use we started
hearing things like this from the family
member in the nursing staff from the
family members she doesn't point to the
bulletin board as she used to do asking
me if I knew all those people so by
repeating this process she's gradually
relearning who these people are so now
the nurse was saying never before would
she show her who these people were in
the pictures were but now she will
she'll point to the family pictures on
the wall and tell me who they are and
then the other daughters also saying
things like this process of revisiting
these family photos is helping her
relearn who people in her family network
are okay so why was this case successful
we can say it's successful because of
these because of a couple reasons one as
I mentioned any sort of engagement we're
seeing when the norm is really
withdrawal in isolation especially in
the last year of your life Ethel was
quite socially withdrawn and and didn't
really want to interact with anybody
before bringing this sort of technology
into her life and so we saw some
improvements and that was really
exciting and encouraging even for an in
of one case study but this is really a
case of this older adult family group
collectively authoring these materials
and I'd argue that this photo album in
the the the digital pen system we
created was at just the right level of
abstraction they were able to do what
they wanted to do in an efficient and
clear manner with it and not much more
but it also really drew on their
existing photo sharing practices which
is quite important right they weren't
asked to shift their practices to
looking at these photos now on an iPad
or something and in fact at one point we
took away the book and started to do an
analysis and Alice wrote to us and said
we really need that back you know we
we've stopped watching TV in the
evenings and we've started looking at
this book and now you know mom really
misses it now that you've taken it back
for your analysis could we please have
it back
she said I've also tried to show her
photos on an iPad and she says no put
them in the book I don't want anything
to do with that so for this particular
centenarian this sort of hybrid media
really worked well okay so moving from
that particular
case study where Ethel was involved but
she was not front and center in the
creation process now I'm going to
describe some work from the context of
art therapy involving older adults with
dementia where these individuals are
definitely front and center in the
creation and sharing process we're going
to talk about what that means for
thinking about sharing and participating
in online social environments through
therapeutic artwork okay so dementia is
marked by a significant decline in
cognitive ability that affects your
language and your memory it can be a
very isolating experience as well
linked with anxiety depression in
society really tends to view dementia
when you think about dementia you don't
have a warm fuzzy about it right when
I'm talking about this it's not an
exciting topic you guys are here last
class of this mint or a quarter thank
you for doing that dementia is not an
exciting topic but hopefully today it
will be and so what we're gonna do is
think about this typical positioning of
people with dementia in our society and
we're gonna turn it on its head we're
gonna study the context of art therapy
and so we've been working art therapy
for over two years now and also
interviewing a variety of art therapists
in addition to our observations art
therapy is all about self-expression
it's a way of when a person does not
have words maybe not the ability or the
desire to produce language they can
create art as a way of expressing their
desires and their needs and their own
experience with disability so art
therapy is about providing people with a
sense of dignity wherein the rest of
your life you may not be able to choose
what you wear what you eat or where you
go but in art therapy it's all about
empowering people as creators and as
competent and engaged individuals so
what's special about art therapy and I'd
argue the arts more broadly is this this
is a quote from our therapist one of the
one of the main people we've worked with
she says when you're having a creative
interaction with somebody you're not
bound by the normal linear conversation
and socially acceptable rules of what's
appropriate you don't even
necessarily have to be able to speak
coherently to be able to express
yourself creatively right so when we
think about the social rules we have
that prize logic and reasoning those are
far less important in the arts things
like your sensory experience humor
emotional awareness and creativity are
all valued and those are all continuing
strengths of people with dementia but
making and sharing artwork in this
context depends on the facilitating role
of the art therapists remember I said
I'd come back to this intelligent unit
of interaction between a therapist and a
person with dementia or cognitive
impairment and here's where we really
see this this work happening in a deeper
way so the therapists hone what they
call their third hand okay so the third
hand is this is written by a famous art
therapist edith kramer she says it helps
the creative process along without being
intrusive without distorting the meaning
or imposing your own ideas and
preferences on the client you use your
artistic competence and imagination in
empathetic service of other people right
so the therapist is there
their job is to be the third the third
hand like machinery make the physical
work happen so this is a woman with
Parkinson's disease and she's trying to
line up a particular piece of paper on
her her art project right here and so
the therapist comes in at the right
moment and helps her accomplish this and
what the therapist says when we asked
her about this it was always her process
I was the extra hand
that's what a therapist should be doing
by second nature this is a very
empowering process especially as I
mentioned compared to other aspects of
daily life and really seeing art work in
this way is a conceptual shift and we've
written about this in a recent or an
upcoming KY paper it shifts from viewing
dementia as an impairment and it's all
about a deficit and a loss to thinking
about people's behaviors as expressions
of who they are
now this particular woman right here she
had a stroke and so she has some limited
range of motion she she cannot speak
fluently and she has some limited range
of motion in her arm but what she does
is often grabs a paintbrush and does
this rhythmic
motion and so the therapist introduced
art materials to take advantage of this
and now what was usually seen as a
negative symptom of a disease is an
expression of the self and so they're
not painting on you know construction
paper with Crayolas they have fine art
materials so this is a silk scarf that
this woman created and it's her
signature style this style has emerged
over time as she's been in art therapy
and I can tell you this family has vied
over her artwork they're actually
fighting over who gets her artwork it's
become a prized possession so now you
take a person who really is questioning
their role in society and their value
and what they can contribute and you put
them in a position where they're the one
who's able to gift and to to show that
they're contributing back to their own
family okay so some of you may not care
about art therapy or older adults are
aging in general so let me try to give
you a few reasons why I think this
context is really important for design
particularly if you're at all interested
in health and information systems so
what is that we can start to look at the
health benefits we can actually look at
some outcomes of staying socially
engaged through artwork and art making
if we have systems that allow people to
do this so this is a predominantly
offline group of people we're talking
about and what would it mean to create
systems that help them stay connected
over the long term with their loved ones
this is also artwork is an instance of
protected health information so artwork
serves as both an expressive artifact
and as part of the health record right
so it's this boundary object that goes
between these two worlds so there's a
lot that's bound up in that right this
artwork even though we see it as an
expressive artifact is still bound by
HIPAA
so we have ethical and legal
considerations around what it means to
share it and now we start to even zoom
out further and we see that things we
take for granted around sharing in our
own maintaining our own privacy online
are much broader than a single
individual
they involve that individual caregivers
members of the broader care team nurses
doctors family members and most
importantly an authorized representative
so
the older adults we work with have
signed over often their own their own
rights essentially their power of
attorney to a family member and if they
say I'd like to put my art work in an
art show but their family member says
you know this kind of reveals that you
have dementia and we don't want all of
your friends to come and see this so
we're not going to let you put that in
the show this is true this happens the
the the authorized representative can
overstep the bounds of this person being
an artist so again we're able to
understand some of these tensions and
how families are negotiating sharing
these these expressive artifacts
okay so we've started prototyping some
systems what would it mean to capture
this artwork that's produced we created
a Wizard of Oz prototype this is an
interactive frame that has an Android
tablet built into it as I always telling
Camille we spent hours and hours
creating clickable paper buttons for
paper prototyping because we thought
there's something so gratifying about
feeling that click and feeling like you
have made a change in the world and
you've actually had action you you've
taken action here's our Wizard over here
and so we we did some early testing with
older adults in the care facility we
work with to understand sort of button
layout and whether or not this sort of
interactive portfolio of artwork would
would be an okay thing turns out it's a
fine front-end interface but sharing
artwork at a distance that's sort of a
mess what does that mean this research
we're doing was reviewed by two IR B's
pretty strictly and we said yeah sure
you know we have these older adults
they're creating artwork yeah they they
they do have cognitive impairment they
have an authorized representative and we
want them to put it online and people
started to panic thinking what does this
mean you're gonna you know there's
layers of legal ethical and bureaucratic
sort of things that we have to get
through so the important thing here
though is that these individuals have
very limited a very limited sense of
agency in whether and how they'd be able
to share this work more broadly so what
we wanted to do was think about cultural
and embodied forms of sharing the
metaphors that we have as a way of
scaffolding interaction with this system
so for example some early paper
prototype
that we worked on with art therapists
included using physical space as a way
to delineate who you would share with so
you could bring little avatars in and
out of a circle you could use a
scrapbook to provide contextual or
biographical cues about this is a group
of friends so things like privacy
setting Facebook friend lists Facebook
groups that that doesn't really make
sense here so what are the right
metaphors that would make sense we even
tried things like a microphone as a way
of getting people to speak to a public
audience and this turns out this worked
very well a microphone it was very clear
people when they held the microphone and
even a microphone that's not working
they sat up straight they articulated
and they said this is my message that I
want to go beyond the sharing circle
also worked quite well so taking these
insights together we created the moment
system so again this is a higher
fidelity version of the interactive
frame you saw earlier it has the Android
tablet built into it and some Arduino
buttons so we have our clickable buttons
on the screen as well which were quite
important for at least these older
adults we've worked with for reaching in
and being able to take control of the
interface but what's special here is
that again very simple computer vision
going on here we're using the
front-facing camera on the tablet in the
space in front of it and the therapist
can take little codes paper codes and
add them to physical objects and then
when they're brought in front of the
display they can label the data so think
about this is an interactive health
record right you have all of your
information saved and so this particular
person said I don't want anyone else to
see this this is very private to me and
so the therapist here is bringing in
things like a lock a treasure box in a
little trinket box and all these things
say keep to myself just for me right and
so for each individual the therapists
can customize which physical objects
will will be used and how they will
label the data so again so you can kind
of save these settings to the system now
all of this right now is offline as I
mentioned there are multiple layers
we're working through and this is the
kind of system that we're building for
the purpose of understanding some of
these challenges right because we don't
yet know what we don't know
what it means to share online with
cognitive impairment but people wanted
to do things like this so this is like a
postcard where if you bring in an image
of someone and you press scan on the
system that emails the message in the
artwork to that person pretty
straightforward but then people wanted
to do things like this they wanted to
have an online blog they wanted to
contribute to a broader community let
all of their children randomly at any
time they want come and see the content
that they're that they're creating
and so we've mocked this up using a
tumblr blog where now you can press a
button on the system and it publishes
artwork along with the audio comments to
a blog the family can record audio
comments and then that's played back
through the frame but do we need you
know what what would make this work
closed password-protected is that enough
do we need the legal representative in
the loop somehow making a decision right
saying no I'm not quite sure I want you
to share this this has you know I can
see your oxygen tank I can see your
wheelchair I don't want other people to
see this so other people are going to be
weighing in on these decisions as they
already do for offline sharing so we're
looking at what sorts of mechanisms
should be embedded in a system to do
this and this is sort of a straw man for
us to discuss right there's a lot wrong
here and a lot we're missing so I'd love
to come back to this in the discussion
okay so one very last study I'll touch
on quickly goes deeper into the work of
caregivers for people with cognitive
impairments so this is based on focus
groups with 20 caregivers of individuals
with cognitive impairments so we wanted
to understand what they're doing in
terms of managing online life for their
care recipients so we heard stories like
this you know this woman saying my
husband suffers from aphasia mostly
communication challenges but your
memories affected when you're working on
aphasia and I'm very aware of you know
when he comes and goes she says some
days he'll stare blankly at the computer
and she needs to step in and help him
other days he's just fine off on his own
so she's really coming and going as
needed but then she said you know
recently he had his identity stolen this
is more and more of a problem I know
you've all seen it in the news it's
significant many people are subject to
elder abuse and financial
left maybe you have your own personal
experience with this and people in your
family
despite this event she still helps her
husband go online because it is so
important to his quality of life and who
he is as a person right so to me that's
pretty significant you could have a very
poignant event like that and still want
people to be active and engaged online
so in terms of caregivers we know a lot
about the physical emotional and social
stress of caregiving it's an intense
burden and so we've started designing
technologies in HCI that can solve
problems around like remote caregiving
now you don't have to go over to a place
to check on a loved one you can sort of
check remotely but there's not a lot out
there that says what are caregivers
doing to support the online lives of
their care recipients so that's what
we're studying here what we found
through our participants is that
caregivers describe their support very
much like the third hand is coming and
going trying to fade into the background
when they were not needed so one person
said it's like a roller coaster it's up
and down it's a vicious cycle and it's
not just going down and staying down
he'll go down then I'll come back up a
little so they don't want to restrict
them in some way as people are sort of
coming and going and in terms of their
abilities so we identified four forms of
work that caregivers were doing today
I'll just present two of those the first
form of work caregivers are performing
is connecting so they're doing a lot to
make their care recipient feel that
they're connected in their online world
so one thing and one reason for this is
just like with ethel and her photo album
they have a belief that visiting sites
like facebook and looking at people in
your network is actually beneficial that
that's actually going to help in the
long run people remember who is in their
network and remember those social
relationships but they're also doing
things like posting on behalf of their
care recipient you know one person said
i'll post pictures i'll say daddy went
outside today or daddy was able to dress
himself so they're trying to post things
that are positive and showing that this
person is still active and engaged and
making the rest of their network aware
of their life experience but at times
this can really conflict
so sometimes family members will post
inappropriate things like daddy was in
diapers right and the caregivers and the
family members sort of get in fights and
go back and forth about what's the
appropriate level of disclosure
especially when our goal is to make sure
this person feels connected and involved
in our little online world now the
second form of work that caregivers do
is what we call protecting so caregivers
are regularly going through in filtering
and removing distressing content from
the news feeds of their care recipients
they do this through really really
inefficient strategies they may share
account credentials right and so they go
in so that they have a single account
that they're using and the caregiver
goes through and make sure there's
nothing distressing like for example one
individual encountered the same story of
a train wreck four or five different
times and every time they would read the
article they would become distressed and
anxious and their caregiver would need
to come to them and calm them down
they'd go away forget they had that
experience come back experience it again
so caregivers just out of desperation
say we can't do this we can't even post
about disasters as a family we have to
get together and start raining in the
content that these that that are Karaca
pants seeing so they're developing these
workarounds like I said sharing
passwords or even setting up email
filters one thing that really surprised
me too is that they're going through the
person's network and they're deleting
and defriending people who may be doing
things that they consider inappropriate
caregivers were really divided on this
some said yeah it's my job to make sure
there's no one in their network doing
these things others said no it's not
really my job these were his friends
before his accident or before the onset
of dementia so I'm just gonna let him
you know interact with them I'll do
damage control and deal with it after
the fact so what's really clear here is
that caregivers lack the sorts of
mechanisms and tools to do the types of
filtering and protecting work that they
desire and do that in a way that's still
empowering of their care recipient okay
so coming back to this little diagram
what does this mean now that we know a
little bit more about how caregivers
might react in an online so
tuition does that mean they need to then
approve everything the information
that's going both directions that seems
a little obsessive or a little too much
to me but you never know some caregivers
might and then what about the rest of
the family network how can we harness
them what about the sharing and
retweeting and reposting that happens to
say a person's online blog that's that's
showing signs of dementia so these are
big questions and there are really no
clear answers here I'd love to talk
about it more and I think you know
that's where I'll stop today I think we
have a few questions for us but I hope
number one I've convinced you of the
complexities of designing for online
experiences throughout older adulthood
that's the first thing the second thing
is sort of a call to action I hope I've
also convinced you that we are
dreadfully underprepared for what's
happening with future generations of
online activity as everyone in this room
ages you know your cognitive impairment
is not an automatic fate it's it's there
are lots of different theories around
why it happens and why it doesn't but
it's still a situation where our you
know single user centric mindset a
single user accounts for a lot of the
systems we have are breaking when we
know that caregivers and care recipients
become very intertwined towards the end
of life okay so with that I would be
glad to wrap up and I want to thank my
colleagues who have contributed to this
research and I look forward to
discussing this more with Camille thank
you
[Applause]